these parents have had to fight to prove
their baby's deaths in Nottingham were
caused by failures in care
Harriet Hawkins was stillborn in 2016
three years later winter Andrews passed
away soon after being born far from
being isolated cases they now know they
were victims of what's set to be the
biggest maternity scandal in the NHS as
we're talking about empty car sites
talking about tiny white coffins you
know and this was all preventable I feel
basically we haven't been able to grieve
Harriet has just been this continuous
fight it's not easy to hear that hard
they'd done things differently had they
listened to the Hawkins family then
winter would probably still be here
because they would have learned from the
failings there's the two of more than
1700 cases from this trust now being
investigated by this independent midwife
why do you think things have gone so
catastrophically wrong here in
Nottingham what I can say is I've seen
an awful lot of evidence that local
Nottinghamshire families were simply not
listened to they were disregarded they
were pushed away and the door was closed
and with that culture
learning is going to be lost at a public
meeting the chair of the NHS trust
admitted bereaved families had been
ignored
for too long we have not listened to
women and families who have been
affected by failings and our maternity
services
and this brick wall approach has caused
additional pain and this must change
they've been told they will now be heard
but for so many families it's too late
Becky Johnson Sky News Nottingham